[Music]
badass scientists news scious
submitted I love you Barton Geo all
thank you a scientist pulled himself out
of a 70-foot premise the bus what's a
cravat like a big hole it's a cracking
of glacier oh that's a nightmare that's
easy while we [ __ ] him he was
exploring polar bears and penguins
wasn't looking
everything was why it looks the same
that is why they say body system when we
went to Honolulu Bay and snorkel they
said make sure you go into the water
with a partner and you see each other
yep that's responsive they're not
supposed to go alone you're never spawn
off I always go unload me too yes this
man today was John all he's 47 no he was
44 at the time when this happened
he was trapped for three years in the
crevice no I guess is pronounced crowbar
ha ha so he's a professor of geography
and environmental studies sounds fun at
Western Kentucky University he lacks
rocks
he uses his research to show how climate
is changing and affecting mountain
ranges that's what he does you ain't
gotta tell me that I know this professor
he was at the hem Himalayan always be
going there hmm so he was there he was
going to get water and to collect some
snow samples for his research when he
accidentally fell in this crevasse he
fell 70 feet down long as yellow yeah
you know that's falling like seven
stories I don't suppose she didn't die
from the fall I think that way so this
is like miraculous like he can survive
this at all so heat luckily was able to
land on like a three-foot ledge but he
could have still kept falling so much
are you video clip he started filming
while he was falling no no did he lost
70 feet worth or was the crack 70 feet
but he only fell down a certain way just
slid all the way down you fell 70 feet
there was still we don't know how this
without a camera he did it on purpose
let's continue
oh my god one broken arm he looks like a
[ __ ] Viking backward slash my arm I
can use [ __ ] well he broke his arm how
climb although I just like the runners
uninjured legs that's what he did armed
with only a tech sketch tool and with
the rest of his team asleep for a second
base camp John turned to a platform that
he knew would gather global attention
Facebook has messages red reception SQ
another life to survive - nice nice I
feel better
but so cold and longest night ever
my right arm was in piercing agony thank
God
John was part of a scientific team
looking at the climate's effect on
mountain areas his team had moved to a
second camp leaving him in what he
described as a safe zone I have looked
over the edge into the okay and I know
that's not where I wanted to be and now
I can really really appreciate living
and being with my friends and family and
Facebook he's known the pool in one face
Lucas T on BBC news man my phone service
is so garbage I would have no reception
so his friends found him and helped him
out no so what he had to do is he
uploaded these messages on facebook and
in somebody contacted us for attack yeah
so then Global rescue were able to find
him once he was able to climb out so I
took them I think it was six hours with
one arm with one of you climbed out by
himself so he didn't even need help took
him six hours to crawl out of the hole
in another three hours just to get to
his tent so what about his homies
[ __ ] still sleeping and [ __ ]
no so they were already at another
campsite this was a [ __ ] bad-ass
apparently there had been an avalanche
so then they had to move the camp but he
stayed behind for some reason mm-hmm
that's crazy
he had five broken ribs internal
bleeding his whole face was busted he
his fingers got frostbite that sounds
horrible and he was able to get out of
that alive it's just so amazing it's
crazy you they listen I would have been
accepting death or I would have I would
have used the first hour to [ __ ] cry
the next 15 minutes
[ __ ] jacking off then that would've
died hey what's your what good ass
or last time one last time [ __ ] dead
when it comes to cooking here we have
the beloved ruler of Jabalia who died
John Huey's 240 pounds he's 6 feet 5
inches tall so the man climbing himself
out which is one good awesome big
[ __ ] it would have taken the
average person a lot longer than yeah
yeah he could Kika reach more you know
what's crazy that just shows how
resilient his human spirit is that's
[ __ ] six hours to climb out the first
hour done it's like this never ends [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'm just got to go deeper
maybe hopefully I'll come out the other
side of the China just to see what says
well you know if you're in the North
Pole and then you go to the South Pole
you're just from cold to Kailash [ __ ]
that's right I forgot yeah there's the
thing on Facebook bro this is his friend
John's broken arm ribs internal bleeding
well 70 feet crevasse [ __ ] calm
please
this was like please call global rescue
can't find a helicopter I'll try to
survive it all right dude I'm so upset
at myself do when I text people normally
I have 40 typos this will doesn't have
any at all
yeah no typos with one hand and he's
freezing with frostbite wouldn't you
just Google Maps your [ __ ] location
and pen where you are in a glacier yeah
I didn't take a picture of that and send
it on Facebook he did give the location
but they're saying that global rescue so
this post think you did global risk you
can't find a helicopter so I'll try to
survive tonight I crawled back to tent
unless the bleeding inside gets me I
should survive the next one bleeding
inside feels better but so cold pain
running low longest night ever he is the
calmest [ __ ]
find out and then he started typing yeah
six hours to climb out tree to get to
his tent yeah he doesn't use a single
exclamation mark yeah he deserves to
survive he's not panicking at all he's
just like talking about internal
bleeding like it's nothing just bleeding
inside
I feel like panicking would make it
worse because your blood pressure goes
up that's true you gotta try our best
not to panic because then if your blood
pressure rises and [ __ ] radiation it
wouldn't be better though since he's
cold oh maybe it's most [ __ ] insane
that Dan was a hero
this all happened back in 2014 his book
is out now it's called ice ball where he
wrote his entire experience it's almost
like being in a fight where 3 minutes
feels like 4,000 hours and then the your
head is just spinning and turning and
it's like [ __ ] and there's so much to
reflect back on and think about
especially because he thought he was in
a safe zone like he was just watching
like oh I'm good
and he spits on a banana peel it was
covered so it's kind of like a like a
quicksand trap or whatever it's like
there was a oh my god that's the qurba
CA hey guys thanks for watching that
last episode did you love it
I know you did so make sure to give this
video a big thumbs up and to watch more
videos you can watch em up with here
[Music]
[Music]